[Music]
Hollywood just send it on Sin City to
watch boys Mayweather take down Conor
McGregor Anna Carly still was there for
all the ringside actions
you guys got Floyd Mayweather economy
Gregory McGregor who are you supporting
tonight
Oh can't can't give it away my man
moneymaker
the celebrity split as to who they are
supporting only ET is here ringside look
at JLo and a-rod they jet it in for
showtimes fight of the century and yes
j-rod made the jumbotron just one row
behind Jenny from the block in her live
X Diddy and a black hat he had a moment
with Steve Harvey and with Jamie Foxx
Jamie was down to party with the
everybody with the guys but the ladies
excuse us Shirley's her co-star Chris
Hemsworth was clear on who he was rootin
for and more star run-ins check out Leo
with Kevin Connolly on one side and
party boy Orlando Bloom on the other
[Music]
Jimmy Livanos laid the national anthem
and posed with Chantenay weather and
with McGregor backstage the Irishmen
lost but got much of loss from this
spirited Scotsman who was expecting the
unexpected I'm looking forward to try
this misty could but it couldn't do it
no any weather was to talk all right
well Jamie Foxx's party fouled Don
Cheadle also had this to say about his
oceans co-star George Clooney big a new
dad you're gonna be a terrible father
and if you have any any sense at all you
will hand your kids to me right away oh
don't say you really build on he is such
a joker yeah but if he's giving you the
business that means he loves you that's
right so it's all good
[Music]
you